welcome to this video playing women
international master and in helen ellen
hog is author or something and then haga
sorta i'm probably butchering this up
okay let's see he got a dutch defense i
played Bishop g5 early to read you she's
going to take the pawn here okay let's
um let's see if black insists on taking
this I'll just develop pieces and see
what happens
yeah she's not taking however if you're
not going to take on be too then why did
you play between 226 m five yeah 5
lights for
mmm this is all very very suspicious
only 5 i'm playing c5 that's the idea to
be honest i really think black should
take me to otherwise oh yeah otherwise
it simply didn't make any sense what to
a black plate okay so castles yeah I
mean I'm not sure really could ye 5e
fibers is coming
hmm
yeah the c5 threatened
quite sure what to do here let's let's
play this first I mean black has nothing
developed absolutely nothing so
let's drop the spec the I am I know but
still if for my desk there's a sacrifice
which is at least dangerous and also see
for fc5 evil hmm or or or evil myself ya
black ass plakias playing with fire here
I'm only I'm far behind on the clock but
this is very dangerous for black that
was the neighbors doorbell maybe I need
to close that door of my room here to
avoid who sounds okay what should like
to yeah this is one way to go I need to
I need to be able to to move maybe black
and lacy five now c5
I must instead of castles I need to
place you five myself okay she didn't
take the chance c5 was a was very
problematic now I'm I'm getting I'm
getting compensation yeah okay this is
just like fire away now just open up the
position push-up to g6 let's foreign
takes on your is also good check let's
let's make sure that the king is is is
out of castling Reitz takes here need to
I need to I need to get a five probably
i need the smooth
threatening night c4 and takes only five
yeah no I'm no I'm covering c5
hmm not be 70 singing okay let's take
that
ok need to need to open up the position
Queen f4 I am night c4 and queen f4
going on the king this check must be
dangerous at least ok I can take on I
can to f7 I teggy five and i are kicking
let's let's do that I want 40-something
second some night we night c4 I am
we first us do this
can go to go to a hero here check
yeah I'm completely out of time here yet
time Bernie to probe Leah this is not
working yeah dad's was winning before no
doubt about that but what about this
position is there some some chance to I
have some threads here but that winning
I always is there something substantial
I think Luke evade and threatening Queen
have six obviously she can give this
check not sure if this is this is
probably not good rook fh yeah Queenie
forum check yeah this is probably a
mistake the check I don't believe in
chat gives me this additional idea check
check
I def Queen f2 is from the improbably
possibly a check don't see a med
checkmate this is a mate Wow poor what
deck yeah this was the only idea left a
three with cream before made there's
there's no check here a queer night a4
check but this is not a win all night if
I is a win but ok who is going to see
that wow what a game I mean yeah many
things were missed here he or she must
he she she absolutely must play c5 and I
think then then I'm in trouble because
it's so closed I probably needed to play
c5 first and then take here or something
like that to make sure it opens up and
then I should have very good play at
least compensation I'd c5 would have
been yeah now I'm breaking through and
multiple interesting moves also where
this was interesting that this is just a
very lonesome king okay check this
briefly check many possibilities f3 was
good here okay yeah but difficult until
Bishop f4 win so I played that check
Luka takes and now I can the computer
sees a meteor and made Queen B 1
made Wow yeah I felt like there is
something but I didn't find it Queen B 1
Jim this is very straightforward and on
this the screen be three it's really
made into morcilla know where black is
going to defend it Jenny so I gave the
check this also wins still Queen B 1
this is losing yeah I had it what I
actually wanted to do before I add water
to sec and take here and this is in fact
also winning check this is also what
what's the computer signal said wrong
but this is a draw probably a perpetual
Wow ok this is what I played no Chang
yeah this was desperation check but it
seems to be great the computers has
white is better here still wow what a
wacky game check ok this losses and here
i am i winning how am i winning ok r
this is nice when just looks looks ok
but it's losing I can do I can't play
Queenie for and the point is if he she
goes back yeah then I mean then it's a
meeting attack pretty czech pretty
straightforward j check i'm getting all
the pawns and i'm meeting at the end but
what check this I didn't have time to
catch it but this is the point check
it's very nice Bishop takes Queen e1 and
the g4 check check King takes check
check this this one and this is also
winning very nice of course impossible
who's ten seconds she so I just yakking
at five again losers picking age five
wins I don't have a medium King f5
chocolate eggs and now f3 of course f3
check winning the Queen ah I know I
didn't see ji only what I wanted to give
checks here this is a draw okay yeah I
our queen e forse winning this is what I
play it here and now I played a 3 does
this trap with Queen before and what is
how is this winning Jack needed me same
check check computer chess check need to
go here and then just one okay I'm
winning the Queen and yeah as it turns
out I'm my backpack porns up and I still
have an attack like this yeah not sure
what is winning computer says so button
unclear wow what a game yeah I hope you
enjoyed it epic thanks for watching